♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
CHARLES M. BLOW:
I'm trying to find a way
we can lift the burden
off the shoulders
of Black people,
of white supremacy.
What if we skip over
all that hoping?
all the pleading and the begging
and the marching
and the shouting
and go straight
to the power?
During the Great Migration,
about six million Black people
left the South for cities
in the North and West.
I suggest that Black people
return to the states
with the highest percentages
already of Black people,
where they can gain
political power.
If we're gonna make a go of it,
the South makes a lot of sense.
CHARLES: I was shaking
and nervous,
maybe even afraid about
leaving New York for Atlanta.
I have convinced myself
that this is
what we must do
as Black people.
SPEAKER: I don't know if you
could convince that many people
to move that way.
The argument of like,
"I ain't going South,"
is that much different from,
"Hey, up North,
let's get this together."
You are encouraging
Black Chicago to stay here,
-stay intact.
-I am. This is our city.
I want for Black boys to live
in a world
where they do not have
to think about
protecting their humanity.
Those who don't want to see
sharing of that power
will do all that they can
to waylay that situation.
SPEAKER 2:
There is the X factor
of these
voter suppression bills.
Every freedom is at stake.
There are some things in life
that are bigger than you.
It has to be about
community success.
We are the cavalry
we've been waiting on.
I have to figure out
if I am
being an apostle of Black power
or am I chasing windmills.
We gotta get back and claim,
really, what we built.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪